everybody always calls me like hey Blac
Chyna China China nobody never really
calls me Angela so sometimes I would
kind of like forget like who I am
because it's always like about the brand
brand but not about the person yeah so
Blac Chyna going back to her Roots yes
ma'am in a new interview with Forbes the
star opens up about her decision to step
back from her stage name what do you
want to be referenced as Blac Chyna or
are you Angela White Angela White it was
given to me by birth
um but mostly just for me it's like
getting back to myself because you know
being in the entertainment like feel
everybody always calls me like hey Blac
Chyna is always like about the brand
brand but not about the person yeah so
I'm just I'm ready to get back to Angela
like Blac Chyna like black China is
black China you know what I mean and I
feel like I've outgrown that yeah and
it's just time for like a change the
switch-up comes after the mom of two
Reef recently made a big transformation
when she decided to reverse her cosmetic
surgeries
uh
reduce and also to my breasts because
honestly I feel like
I'm like past that stage I've been there
done that this is actually my fifth time
hopefully my last time getting my
breasts done it's time for like a change
basically first of all I'm tired of the
look and it's just not flatter and it's
just not what I look like the 34 year
old model documented her journey on
Instagram I'm in recovery mode right now
got my bandages on
as you can see
got my breasts reduced one of the best
decisions I could have done in a very
long time and shared her biggest
motivation to remove her implants and
fillers and I'm trying to set an example
for my kids Angela's mom to two-year-old
son King Cairo with Tyga and
six-year-old daughter dream with Rob
Kardashian this part of my life is like
really important you know I'm changing
you know and I want to grow old with my
kids I wanna
be with my kids I want to have grandkids
I want to you know further my career
other things that I'm doing
and I just really feel like this is just
really holding me back you know and
hopefully it will not hold me back
anymore and I'm still on my I'm still on
my journey but she makes it clear
despite it all it's not a forever
goodbye to Blac Chyna it's definitely
not the the end of Blac Chyna I think
now it's more the separation of it
you know it's like um if I'm performing
and things like that that's Blac Chyna
like if I'm home and I'm with the kids
and I'm or if I'm doing my business
stuff and I'm doing deals that's Angela
like how we're just sitting right here
and we're having a conversation this is
Angela now we go and we gotta go get
Glam hair nails makeup we got costumes
that's definitely Blac Chyna
foreign